the man at the center of the popular
podcast serial will get a new murder
trial a jury convicted Adnan Syed in
2000 in 2000 murdering his high-school
sweetheart he was sentenced to life in
prison at that time but an appeals court
yesterday threw out his conviction
because of a witness featured in the
popular podcast chip Reid is at a public
library in Woodlawn Maryland which
played a pivotal role in this appeal
chip good morning this is amazing story
good it is a good morning and a witness
says Adnan Syed was here at this library
at the exact moment the prosecutors say
he was out committing murder but that
witness did not tell her story until 14
years after the trial after serial
tracked her down Asia McLean told serial
she could provide an alibi for Adnan
Syed during the 1999 murder of Haman Lee
she says they were high school students
then hanging out at this library after
school at the same time prosecutors say
Lee was being murdered in a park about
three miles away
I think Asia like you might be that
technicality on Thursday a Maryland
appellate court ordered a new trial
saying syed likely wouldn't have been
convicted if his lawyer had called
mcclain to the witness stand there is
reasonable probability that MacLaine's
alibi testimony would have raised a
reasonable doubt in the mind of at least
one juror the judges ruled all the
charges have been vacated it's
incredible Rabia Chaudhary is the author
of odd Nan's story she is a family
friend who brought ciouds case to serial
non is not the only victim here there is
a victim of murder here her name is
Haman Lee they need to reopen the
investigation and look for the person
who actually killed her no one able to
provide any shred of evidence anything
but friendships words like love and
respect for her had no reason to kill
her syed now 36 has spent more than half
of his life behind bars his case
received renewed interest after cereal
raised questions about his conviction in
2006
the 12-episode podcast was reportedly
downloaded more than 175 million times
the most ever for a podcast I don't
think we'd be where we are today without
serial Justin Brown Syed's appellate
attorney called the podcast a
game-changer
it's Bill you know hundreds of thousands
of supporters all over the country it
has helped fund our efforts it has
helped investigate and that has made a
huge difference our efforts to reach the
family of hae min Lee were unsuccessful
and so far prosecutors have not said
whether they're going to appeal Nora
what a story it's an amazing story and
it's riveting too you know I kept
reading about it hearing about it so I
started listening I said I'll listen to
one or two and before you know it you've
written stop you're at episode number
eight yeah and then you can't wait to
finish up highly recommend it and you go
back and forth I went back and forth
then I'm glad he's getting a new trial
you know